عاد الهدوء الى محافظات الجنوب وذلك بعد
احداث داميه وقعت في مدينه الحسينيه وقتل
فيها نائب ومدير امن معان واصيبت ناني
اخره
المستمر لاسعار المحروقات وعزست قوه الامن
الاردني مداخل المدن الجنوبيه لاسيه في
مدينتي الكرك والحسينيه بعد قيام المحتجين
باغلاق الطرق وحرق الاطارات وتعطيل حركه
السيرته الامن العام الاردني من عواقب
ارتكاب ما وصفتها بالافعال الجرميه
والتخريبيه التي يحرض البعض عليها ويشهدوا
الاردن موجه احتجاج منذ نحو اسبوعين بداها
سائقو الشاحنات للمطالبات بتخفيض اسعار
المحروقات
لتتمدد الى اشكال النقل العموميه وسيارات
الاجره في مدن عده
ينضم الان الينا من مديريه مدينه الحسينيه
في الجنوب الاردن مدير مكتب الجزيره حسن
الشوبكي اهلا بك حسن اذا حدثنا عن الوضع
اين وصلت الامور
ليلى كانت يعني الليله الماضيه صعبه
للغايه على الامن وعلى الاردنيين عموما
وشاهدت هذه المنطقه نحن في الحسينيه على
بعد 200 كيلو متر من جنوب العاصمه
الاردنيه
الحياه يعني بعد فجر اليوم عادت الى
الهدوء بعد ان السيطره الامن على الاحداث
التي همم اندلعت والمواجهات التي اندلعت
همم يعني همم مساء امس هنا وهنالك يتواجد
امني كما ترون في الكاميرا
لقوات الدرك الاردنيه
وكذلك هنالك حضور يعني فرق همم البحث ال-
ال- الجنائي التابعه للامن العام وكان
هنالك يعني عمليات تفتيش في همم هذه
المنطقه ااه خلفنا
بحث همم
للكشف عن ما تم همم من انت هتطلاق الرصاص
التي يعني اصابت بموجبها تم اصابه راس
العقيد عبد الرزاق دلابيح نائب محافظ
النائب محافظ مدير شرطه معان هل همم
اصيب يعني في الراس واسعفه على الفور الى
مستشفى معان معان تبعد نحو 50 كيلومترا
الى الجنوب خلفنا ايضا الحسينيه همم يعني
تضم بدو الجنوب وهي لواء يتبع الى محافظه
معان همم الاشتباكات كانت بالامس هناك في
الحسينيه وكذلك في عدد من المدن الجنوبيه
الكرك ايضا كان هناك اغلاقات للطرق في
الشارع المحادثه لقلعه الكرك وكان هنالك
ايضا اشتباكات في الشؤون الجنوبيه وفي
ناعور وفي مادبا همم اغلاق طرق وغيره وهنا
هذا الطريق يربط ايضا همم
عمان بالعقبه لذلك هو طريق سياحي وطريق
بري للشحن والنقل مهم جدا لم نشهد اي
اغلاقات منذ اتينا من ساعات الصباح الباكر
الطريق مفتوحه الهدوء نسبي طبعا سيطر
الامن على همم طول وامتداد الطريق يعني
راينا على امتداد الطريق منذ الجيزه الى
منطقه القطراني الى الحساء بمرورا مثلث
الكرك وصولا الى هنا الحسينيه وفيما بعد
الى معان ثم الى العقبه طريق يعني هناك
تعزيزات امنيه كبيره متواجده وكان هنالك
بيان للامن العام قال فيه انه يضمن همم
التعبير السلمي للمتظاهرين لكنه شكرا من
حديد كل من وصفهم بالمخربين او المخارجين
على القانون وهمم هنالك ايضا اصابه الى
ضابط وضابط صف من الامن العام وهما همم
قيد العلاج في هذه اللحظه شكرا لك حسن من
حسينيه جنوب الاردن